vuoi
sposarmi Sì aspetta Dov'è
L'anello ce l'ho
fatta questo deve essere il mio giorno
fortunato ma tu non sei Capuccetto
Rosso Ahia eccoti qua Ma tu chi sei
nonna
siamo nuovamente nei cartoni animati
nella vita reale Ma in quale cartone
sono Se solo ci fosse uno
specchio perché non c'è nessuno in
questo cartone animato se voi sapete In
che cartone animato sono scrivetelo nei
commenti e mi raccomando cliccate mi
piace Ora provo a uscire da questa
stanza visto che non c'è nessuno
qua sono rinchiusa qua dentro Ma perché
proviamo queste altre
porte
non c'è niente da fare sono rinchiusa
forse devo aspettare che arrivi
qualcuno principessa è arrivato il
momento dell'incoronazione mi segua pure
così possiamo iniziare la cerimonia in
coronazione posso quindi uscire da
questa camera finalmente e scoprire In
quale mondo mi trovo Certo Certo vengo
subito
andiamo Eccoci qua arrivati nel salone
reale Le chiedo di accomodarsi così
posso andare a recuperare la corona
tranquillamente Ok allora aspetto qua
allora Io
vado Chissà in quale cartone animato
sono finita la cosa bella è che sto per
diventare principessa ma dove sarà
Vitale
Elsa Come va Ma tu chi sei Ma cosa stai
dicendo sono tua sorella Ho delle
domande per te da da troppo tempo che
non ci vediamo eh Cosa hai fatto tutto
quel tempo chiusa in camera eh ti sono
mancata quando sei
cresciuta sì sì sì eh ho fatto ascolta
posso chiederti già che ci siamo in Che
cartone ci troviamo Elsa tutto quel
tempo chiuso in camera ti deve avere
congelato il cervello Cosa stai dicendo
aspetta aspetta Devi capire che io in
realtà non faccio parte di questo
cartone sono qua per salvarlo È per
quello che ti ho chiesto in quale
cartone ci troviamo e quindi sono
semplicemente qui per
salvarlo presto principessa è il momento
dell'incoronazione Ah ok sì sì sì Sono
super contenta di diventare una
principessa che bella quella corona Ma
dov'è il principe Vabbè non fa niente
ecco
qua sei splendida Grazie sorellina Ehi
Anna sono qui Sono arrivato da molto
lontano col mio spinato Destriero
Merlino Non vedo l'ora di vederti apro
la porta per
favore torna qui
[Musica]
Merlino Scusami sorellona C'è un mio
amico devo andare a salutarlo
Perdonami ma dove stai andando Anna Eh
vabbè Eh devo capire come salvare questo
cartone ancora e trovare Vitale Anna
aprii per favore apri una porta
h Cosa ci fai qui son venuto perché so
che ci conosciamo da poco ma non ti
sembra così strano che cosa che siamo
così simili stavo per dirlo io senti so
che ci conosciamo da poco ma stavo
pensando a una cosa vuoi
sposarmi Sì ma aspetta Dov'è l'anello
eh costava un po' troppo l'anello non fa
niente
sì
Elsa devo darti una notizia io e Hans ci
sposiamo Non sei contenta per me eh vi
sposate Ma scusa Da quanto tempo mi
conoscete da quando ci conosciamo hai
detto Beh dà già un po' di tempo
tipo
quore Beh Elsa mi darai la tua
approvazione Ti prego voglio tanto
sposarmi con lui è l'amore della mia
vita
[Musica]
da 4 ore Anna ma sei impazzita non puoi
sposarti con una persona che conosci da
4 ore mi dispiace ma io non ti do la mia
approvazione Ma come puoi non approvare
non ci tiene alla mia felicità Questa è
la mia occasione di essere felice Non
puoi sposare una persona che conosci da
4 ore chiunque lui sia quindi io non
approvo questo matrimonio no Noi ci
sposeremo perché l'amore può anche
battere il tempo tu chi sei io sono Hans
e sono un nobile principe conosciuto per
le sue valorose avventure Elsa tu non
sai niente di me sei rimasta chiusa in
quella camera tutti quegli anni non mi
conosci ma non è colpa mia era per la
tua sicurezza io non posso spiegarti ma
non posso lasciarti sposare lui mi
dispiace ma non posso tu lo sai quanto
ho sofferto senza la tua presenza mi
dispiace ma non posso tu non mi conosci
las
Principessa Anna
Anna che cosa ha fatto Anna stai bene
Anna principessa si deve assolutamente
allontanare è troppo
pericoloso devo andare
via Principe Sanna tutto bene Oh tesoro
mio cosa ti è successo Rispondimi per
favore tu allontanati No io la amo e son
venuto qua solo per lei Io sono la
guardia reale del castello e ho il
compito di proteggere la principessa
Anna e la principessa Elsa perciò ti
ordino di allontanarti
subito ma che cosa ho fatto dovrei
salvare questo cartone invece di
salvarlo lo sto rovinando ancora di
più io non volevo essere una principessa
Volevo solo salvare questo cartone E ora
cosa faccio a quanto pare ho dei poteri
di ghiaccio Potrei provare a costruire
qualcosa di buono ma magari ho un'idea
Vediamo se il mio libro lacit stregata
mi può aiutare scopriamo assieme la
parola
segreta Eccola qua questa è la parola
segreta potete tradurla Anche voi vi
basta aprire il libro alla pagina
dell'alfabeto
segreto Credo di aver capito cosa devo
fare
proviamo
Eccomi
qua chi sei io sono olaf Vitale ti ha
trovato
finalmente Meno male siamo assieme in
questo cartone potrei aiutarmi a
risolverlo a risolverlo Io sono olaf No
non stai dicendo non sei olaf sei vitale
Il mio fidanzato non ti ricordi ma non
mi vedi c'ho anche c'ho anche la carota
qui ha visto che hai i potere di
ghiaccio Ahia visto che hai poteri di
ghiaccio ti sei rincitrullito un pochino
sì presto dobbiamo salvare il cartone
dai sbrighiamoci Vieni vieni principessa
Elsa Ti devo dire una cosa
importantissima che cosa mi devi dire
con i tuoi poteri di ghiaccio puoi
creare tanti ghiaccioli per olaf al
limone all alla ciliegia alla Barera
alla fragola alla menta Ah no aspetta
alla menta non piace a nessuno però io
lo mangio Comunque non vi preoccupate eh
lo sapevo Sei sempre tu Vitale Pensi
sempre a mangiare Quindi sei proprio
Vitale sono olaf Ascolta mi devi aiutare
io sono la principessa di questo cartone
animato ma ho fatto del male ad Anna
devo riuscire a liberarmi di questi
poteri per non fare più del male a
nessuno risolvere questo cartone però
come faccio Non posso più avvicinarmi ad
Anna perché rischierei di farle del male
con i miei poteri principessa Elsa ma è
molto facile se lei non si può
avvicinare da sua sorella aspetti che
sua sorella si avvicini a lei è così
facile Andiamo adesso però Vitale mi
sembra un po' strano in questo cartone
Che cosa l cesso ma principessa Elsa Sai
per caso se il sole scioglie i pupazzi
di neve perché sono a rischio
scioglimento Sì il sole scioglie i
pupazzi di neve quindi è meglio se ti
sposti dal sole metto all'ombra e e ora
Fammi capire qual è il piano per
incontrare mia sorella Anna e non farle
del male non ti preoccupare adesso
troveremo un piano ma prima ghiaccioli
ghiaccioli ghiaccioli Ma dai Non pensare
ai ghiaccioli Adesso pensiamo Come
tornare da Anna Non ti preoccupare
principessa essa Adesso pensiamo a un
piano però andiamo all'ombra perché mi
sto sciogliendo Sì sì Mettiti all'ombra
Mettiti
all'ombra dove sarà la principessa Elsa
quell' iberg vivente una volta trovata
potrò continuare il mio piano
malefico Ma quindi dove mi stai portando
olaf dai Troll Perché i troll
principessa Elsa la potranno aiutare con
i suoi poteri Ok andiamo dai Troll
Allora
principessa principessa per favore
dobbiamo tornare all andare al castello
Aspetta aspetta Sai per caso se stando
al sole mi posso sciogliere perché sento
che sto continuando a scioglier basta
olaf basta con questa storia io non
voglio tornare al Castello con i miei
poteri rischio di fare ancora del male a
mia sorella Anna quindi non tornerò
principessa Elsa Anna sta morendo Ha
bisogno del suo aiuto dobbiamo are
velocemente ad
arendel Che
cosa Anna sta morendo per colpa mia
rischio di mandare questo cartone
animato in frantumi devo assolutamente
tornare nel castello allora E riuscire a
controllare i miei poteri principessa
L'accompagno io al castello Però ci sono
i gelati al castello Ma non pensare i
gelati Adesso andiamo
Sbrigati Sì presto presto
andate il mio piano malefico sta andando
alla
grande Cosè successo Principessa Anna si
è svegliata per fortuna pensavamo fosse
successo qualcosa di grave lei è svenuta
e la principessa es è scappata mi sento
così
fredda Ecco la spiegazione ai capelli
bianchi forse c'entra qualcosa
probabilmente gli è stato ho gelato il
cuore adesso si spiega tutto ma dov'è
Elsa Elsa è scappata aveva paura Ma io
lo so che non l'ha fatta apposta è mia
sorella lo so che mi vuole bene me lo
auguro che non l'abbia fatto apposta
però non può andare è troppo pericoloso
Io devo sono sua sorella no principe
Sanna No per favore abbiamo manderemo le
le guardie manderemo le guardie non va
da lei è troppo pericoloso potrebbe
mettersi in qualche guaio devo andare io
per forza tocca a me no principe sann
aspetti Oh no Io vorrei tanto aiutarla
ma non posso allontanarmi dal palazzo
reale questa deve essere sicuramente
opera di
Elsa ce n'è un altro di
[Musica]
là deve essere stata lei con il suo
potere di
ghiaccio continuo questo percorso
Vediamo se ne troviamo
altri presto Anna Anna dove sei
Principessa Anna c'è qualcosa là Parla
Oh
No principessa Elsa Per fortuna è qua
Meno male che sta bene Mi sono
spaventata tantissimo Sì ma dimmi subito
dov'è Anna Ho saputo che sta per morire
dov'è ma Anna è uscita a cercarvi Eh ma
quello è di
Anna è vero il bracciale di Anna presto
andiamo a
[Musica]
vedere che cos'è il braccialetto di Anna
Oh ma cosa si fa
qua ce l'ho fatta il mio piano per
prendermi il Truono ha
funzionato c'ha rinchiudo in prigione e
tu tu perché c'eri chiuso qua come ti
permetti liberali subito o ti metto io
in gabbia ho fermato loro fermerò anche
te e adesso che non hai più la tua spada
cosa pensi di fare non la passerai lisha
soprattutto quando troverò Anna Anna
Anna sta morendo Anna morirà presto e la
tua cara Elsa e quel cono gelato sono
intrappolati io potrò diventare
finalmente il re supremo di
arrendell cono gelato Ma io non sono un
con gelato Io sono un bellissimo pupazzo
di neve e conogelato aspetta chi ha
parlato di conogelato Hai per caso un
conogelato Smettila olaf tu non
riuscirai mai a diventare re Anna
tornerà e e ci salverà sicuramente ti
sbagli mia cara quando Anna è stata
colpita da te è stata colpita nel suo
cuoricino e solo un atto di peramore può
guarirla e io non ho intenzione di
baciarla quindi
morirà e dirò a tutti quanti che sei
stata tu ad uccidere Anna con i tuoi
poteri e io passerò per l'eroe che ha
cercato di salvarla E quando tu sarai
fuori dai piedi insieme a questo pupazzo
sarò l'unico re di arendel Oh no non
riuscirò mai a salvare questo cartone
adesso in questa situazione
Meno male che an Era distratto sono
riuscita a scappare adesso devo
assolutamente cercare Anna perché
potrebbe essere l'unica occasione per
poter sistemare le cose devo
assolutamente
andare sento che mi stanno mancando le
forze sono sempre più
fredda non penso di riuscire a cercarla
ancora per
molto Principessa Anna meno male che
l'ho trovata Per fortuna sei
arrivata rego più in piedi non ho più
forze venga le devo spiegare tantissime
cose Hans ha imprigionato sua sorella
Elsa e come aveva ragione quindi Elsa Sì
dobbiamo assolutamente tornare al
Castello forse riusciremo a sistemare le
cose sì Adesso mi sento terribilmente in
colpa non è colpa sua sia tranquilla
Andiamo
Oh che bella Adesso faccio le prove per
diventare re Ora sono re Sì arender non
ha mai visto un re così bello
reggerò come si deve non come avrebbe
regnato quell' iberg vivente e mi
chiameranno il re bello e anche
intelligente e anche simpatico è furbo è
Salvatore Di arendelle e eliminatore di
Principe No quello no solo bello
intelligente furbo simpatico un
eroe credo che
per questa volta abbiamo fallito non
potremo più salvare questo cartone per
la prima volta
falliamo non so cosa succederà a tutti i
personaggi adesso Secondo te cosa
succederà Secondo me principessa devi
utilizzare i tuoi poteri non posso
utilizzarli sono troppo pericolosi
potrei fare del male a qualcuno ma è
l'unica soluzione per poter uscire da
qui usa i tue poteri mio servitore Non è
forse vero che sono il re più bello che
arendel l'ha mai avuto è vero mio
signore lei è il più bello di arendel Oh
ma così mi rendi molto felice di me
stesso ora vai vai ritorno a fare le
prove che bella la vita da re Ehi
Aspetta
guarda prto
Sca Ehi voi come avete fatto SC la mia
prigione adesso vado a salvare Anna e
canto non servirà a niente ormai Anna è
morta per colpa tua e ora mi dispiace
principessa marend ha bisogno di un re
migliore Non è vero non mi dispiace per
niente
Ehi fermo lascia stare mia sorella
lascia stare mia
sorella
Ah Ma com'è possibile
Anna Oh no no il mio piano sta andando a
rotoli Ehi Aspetta solo un gesto del
vero amore può salvarla
Anna Anna Elsa
Grazie e viva ce l'ho fatta Forse ce
l'ho fatta a salvare questo cartone
finalmente Ma com'è possibile perché sta
succedendo tutto questo a me Dovrei
essere R di arandel Anzi io non sarò il
re di arandel è successo Perché solo un
atto di vero amore poteva salvare Anna e
l'amore tra sorelle l'ha salvata basta
non era nei miei piani eliminari tutti
quanti ma purtroppo lo dovevo fare
questo per diventare il re di
arendel Ti sbagli tu non metterai mai
più piedi ad arendel
[Musica]
sì ce l'abbiamo fatta Elsa Scusami se
non ti ho dato ragione dall'inizio avevi
ragione tu non preoccuparti Anna
L'importante che sono riuscita a
salvarti a salvare questo cartone ora
vivrai una vita felicissima qua ad
arendel che avevamo parlato ghiaccioli
fra No non pensare ai gelati adesso
dobbiamo andare subito al prossimo
cartone siamo in ritardo 3 2 1
via
devo portare questo cestino dalla nonna
ma non devo fare tardi perché io devo
tornare dalla mia mamma poi però aspetta
sta già calando il sole devo sbrigarmi
[Musica]
Chissà in quale cartone animato siamo
Fiti ora Oh no Vitale non c'è quindi
vuol dire che è un personaggio in questo
cartone animato e dovrò scoprire chi
dovrò trovarlo Innanzitutto Beh
guardiamoci intorno così scopriremo In
quale animato siamo e se voi non avete
ancora cliccato mi piace Mi raccomando
cliccate un mi piace qua sotto
andiamo
un'umana questo deve essere il mio
giorno
fortunato Io amo mangiare gli
umani Ciao
umana
Ah attenta Attenta c'è un lupo malefico
affamato che che che un lupo e Cosa stai
dicendo Ma tu
sei Cappucetto Rosso Sì sono io però mam
m ha detto che non devo parlare con gli
sconosciuti quindi non dirgli niente Ho
capito In quale cartone siamo e devo
assolutamente fare in modo che il lupo
non la mangi Ascolta devi ascoltarmi
bene tu non fidarti mai del lupo ok
perché e è troppo complicato da spiegare
però Fidati di me che non sono un lupo
non fidarti Vai del lupo Ok va bene Ah
non mi sembra che abbia capito Facciamo
così ti accompagnerò io dalla nonna Così
arriverà stane salva Ehi aspetta un
momento Ma tu come fai a sapere che sto
andando dalla mia nonnina Beh è
difficile da spiegare io posso solo
dirti che io sono un'esperta di fiabe e
cartoni quindi Fidati di me Io ti
proteggerò in questo caso e farò in modo
che tu arriva sana e salva Dai andiamo
andiamo presto sta calando il sole
andiamo dalla nonna presto Va bene mi
fido Ok benissimo andiamo però se mangio
una merendina non dire nulla alla mamma
eh Va bene Non mi ricordo se nella
storia originale un Cappuccetto poteva
mangiare le merendine ma credo di sì sì
puoi mangiarla tranquilla Andiamo
Ah che fame già Anch'io ho fame mi
sgranocchi qualsiasi cosa in questo
momento e ragazzi Ragazzi Ragazzi miei
Lupetti miei bellissimi
lupet e tu che cavolo sei Io sono una
volpe Ma infatti sembravi strano è uno
strano colorito Vabbè Fermi sentite
sentite me sentite me Ho appena trovato
degli umani da mangiare buoni c' la
colina in bocca e dove si trovano Eh va
bene Ho perso un attimo le tracce ma
sono sicuro che li possiamo ritrovare
inl tre insieme ma perché dobbiamo
mangiare per forza gli umani Insomma non
possiamo mangiare qualcos'altro ma tutti
i bravi lupi mangiano gli umani Ma tu
non sei un lupo eh già e quindi io
voglio diventare un lupo e comunque non
è vero esistono anche lupi buoni che
possono diventare amici degli umani Ah
ma cosa dici cosa sentono le mie
orecchie amici degli umani no i lupi No
mai anzi gli umani sono pericolosi per
noi Perché loro hanno paura di noi dei
lupi e infatti se ti avvicini troppo
potrebbero fare di te una pelliccia
pelliccia ero Voglio diventare una
pelliccia sono troppo giovane giusto se
non vuoi diventare una pelliccia andiamo
subito a trovarli e aarc lii secondo me
dobbiamo seguire le tracce poi vedere
dove vanno Esatto Allora usiamo il
nostro olfatto andiamo a cercarli Io non
sono d'accordo
Ah tu non sei d'accordo ver ver E allora
sarai da sola te ne andrai via dal
nostro Branco non mi interessa non mi
servite voi e pensi che ci servi tu a
noi per trovare due
umani andiamo a mangiare Ciao ciao ciao
ciao che
antipatici pensano che non gli serva io
per trovare gli umani quando in realtà
li ho già trovati sono
laggiù perché non salti pure tu ascolta
ma quanto dista la casa della nonna è
qui vicina Se vuoi puoi anche andartene
adesso non ho più bisogno del tuo aiuto
No non posso andarmene devo assicurarmi
che tu arrivi a casa della nonna sana e
salva e che poi torni a casa ma è quella
laggiù sì è proprio quella siamo
vicinissimi viva dai sbrighiamoci il
sole sta calando ma credo che ce la
faremo prima della notte andiamo
la
state attenti i lupi stanno cercando voi
e vi vogliono mangiare Sì ok ma tu sei
un lupo ma io sono buona tu mi sembri un
lupo affidabile In effetti che dici
Cappuccetto ci fidiamo per questa volta
Per me va bene Ok allora andiamo a casa
della nonna presto sbrighiamoci saltelli
tutti insieme Sì E va
bene
Ahia Ma sei stupido Scusami capo Ah va
bene ti perdono solo perché sei stupido
guarda lì quella è la casa degli umani
sicuramente lì c'è qualcuno da
sgranocchiarli solo riuscire ad entrare
sei pronto sono nato pronto Ok allora
andiamo andiamo
[Musica]
ci siamo riusciti sì ce l'abbiamo
fatta E adesso che siamo dentro mia cara
volpe Sì
padrone padrone mi
piace adesso tu dovrei andare a cercare
gli umani che ci sono qui dentro certo e
dopo io verrò e mangerò per primo perché
sono il capo dei lupi poi mi lascerai
qualcosa vero Ti lascerò qualcosa e con
qualcosa intendo le unghie m Buone le
unghie me le mangio tutti i giorni
infatti alcune non le ho più Ah che
schifo Vabbè meglio per
me che faccio fess su vai subito a
cercare
vai Io aspetto
qui Il mio olfato sente odore di
umano l'ho trovata L'ho
[Musica]
trovato m È una nonnina
succulenta eh eh
Cappuccetto Ma chi sei tu Dove sono i
miei occhiali Ah Eccoli sono qua
ma ma tu non sei Cappuccetto Rosso se
per questo tu non sei la nonna Certo
perché io sono
Vitale e adesso vai via e lasciami
dormire Hai
capito questi giovani d'oggi sempre a
disturbare i nonni mentre
dormono
[Musica]
ho paura C'è un umano una nonna unum
nonna non ho capito niente eh calmati
stupida
vol Dov'è il mio cibo è nella sala di là
e c'è una specie di mostro è più pauroso
di noi c'è una specie di mostro di più
pauroso di noi è un essere umano ma mi
fa troppo paura è più paur
di noi un essere umano che fa più paura
di me il lupo cattivo delle fiabe è
proprio impossibile non sarà che sei un
gran Fifone ah riuscirebbe a spaventare
anche te se lo
vedessi Ti fanno paura gli esseri
umani sei proprio Sei proprio una
piccola
Volpina andiamo e poi vedi Infatti fanno
paura gli esseri umani a me di certo
no
allora dov'è questo umano è quello lì
umano sarà un umano o una nonna va bene
umano nonna non fa niente quando si
tratta di cibo Io mangio
tutto
C da guardia Eh
ma sento un buon profumo di
carne cos'è questa
puzza di cane bagnato
nipotino mio dammi un bacino un bacino a
nonna Bacini Bac che
SCH Che schifo c'avevi ragione fa
proprio schifo Io te l'ho detto che
quella è Nua nonna è
brutta non ce la faccio a mangiarla
mangiare mangiare avete detto mangiare
anche voi avete un certo langorino
andiamo insieme a cercare da mangiare
Allora mangiare e perché qui in questa
casa c'è da mangiare è È proprio vero
che fra gente che ha fame ci si intende
Esatto c'ho una fame non mangio da non
so quanti giorni non mangio ma ho
fame possiamo unire le forze Che ne dici
sì sì è un'ottima idea andiamo a cercare
del cibo tutti insieme e ce lo pappiamo
Sì
sì Eccoci siamo arrivati Questa è la
casa della mia nonnina Evviva entriamo
subito allora sì va bene però se
aspettare qui non ci son problemi Eh no
no io devo accompagnarti per essere
sicura che nessuno ti mangerà Nemmeno tu
ti ho detto che io sono diventato un
lupo buono Io non vi mangio a voi umani
io ci credo Devo comunque tenerti
d'occhio va bene entriamo andiamo
la
nonnina Ehi ma perché la porta era già
aperta Non lo so Andiamo D la mia
nonnina adesso
[Applauso]
Ok Ecco la mia nonnina nonna che bello
rivederti Mi sei mancata
tantissimo ma tu chi sei
[Musica]
nonna ma tu non sei la mia
nonna No non sono io eh vuoi cercare del
cibo insieme a noi
Vitale Anita non mi dire che hai
mangiato la nonna Sei sempre il solito
mangiare no no no no no no vi spiego
tutto vi spiego tutto io non ho mangiato
la nonna Oh Anzi ero qui che cercavo del
cibo insieme a due amici lupi e Dov'è la
mia nonnina
Eh Credo di non averla vista Aspetta un
momento cercav il cibo con due amici
lupi No no aspetta che mi sono sbagliato
uno era un lupo l'altro non ho capito
che cos'era era un po' rossiccio Ah Dove
sono Dove sono andati Dove sono andati
eh stavano cercando del cibo insieme a
me penso che siano di là sono loro
quello quelli che vi ho detto io siamo
in pericolo spostatevi di là elaboriamo
un piano per contrastarli non mi
sembravano così furbi e soprattutto
quello rosso era un po' così e così
mezzo scemo non c'è tempo nascondiamoci
va bene Aspetta aspetta prima di
nasconderci e importantissimo che
facciamo in modo che i lupi vadano via
da questa casa perché se ci trovano ci
mangiano Allora prendiamo questo lupo
qui e lo vendiamo via cosa non i lupi No
no no Lei è un lupo buono non hai capito
Siccome sei diventato amico dei lupi noi
ci nascondiamo così non ci vedono e non
ci mangiano mentre noi siamo nascoste Tu
convinci lupi ad andare via da questa
casa e poi Chiudi e bene a chiave va
bene nonna ho solo una domanda e qu è la
parte dove io mangio se riuscirai a
convincere i lupi ad andare via da
questa casa avrai una fantastica
ricompensa che ha portato Cappuccetto
Rosso Sì che bello Posso avere un
anticipo No no no adesso ancora no no no
no no dopo Adesso nascondiamoci tu mi
raccomando convinci lupi e trova una
soluzione per convincermi convinco i
lupi Io nascondo lì che cosa dovevo fare
Non ho mica capito devo convincere i
lupi ad andare via per poi mangiare la
merendina Ma perché quando si tratta di
cibo Non capisco mai niente lupi lupi
dove lupi venite subito qua andatemi da
mangiare Hai
capito SH io mi nascondo qua Speriamo
che Vitale riesca a convincere i lupi ad
andare via altrimenti sicuro Appena ci
vedranno ci mangeranno
[Musica]
io ho paura Speriamo solo che i lupi non
ci facciano
niente Quei lupi sono cattivi io li
conosco bene perciò mi nascondo Anche io
oh no mi devo inventare qualcosa per F
uscire i lupi di casa eh eh lupi forse
c'ho un'idea
lupi lupi è entrato un po' qui Ehi hai
trovato del cibo eh Amici Miei Purtroppo
no eh Non c'è niente Mi sono ricordato
che non c'è niente in casa quindi
dobbiamo uscire usciamo e e troviamo da
mangiare fuori casa Va bene Ma tu ci hai
detto di cercare qua del cibo tu
impazzito Io ho fame anch'io e pure io
c'ho fame eh E che vuol dire se non c'è
niente non c'è niente bisogna uscire
fuori a trovare qualcosa da mangiare no
ma come tu c'hai illuso noi stavamo per
mangiare te poi fai schifo Sei
bruttissimo fai proprio di schifo
proprio brutto brutto Sì fai proprio e e
e abbiamo deciso di non mangiarti Però
tu ci hai detto che noi che che qua in
casa avresti avuto del cibo da darci ed
è per questo che ti abbiamo assecondato
stiamo seguendo il tuo piano Esatto
stupida e brutta vecchietta vecchietto
una nonna ma che cosa volete Non c'ho
niente a casa da mangiare dobbiamo
andare fuori a mangiare e tu adesso ci
stai dicendo che dobbiamo uscire fuori a
mangiare che cosa dobbiamo mangiare
fuori l'erbetta le vacche che cosa
dobbiamo mangiare fuori eh Dobbiamo
trovare qualcosa da mangiare Spero io ho
fame
cheo ma Eh sì lo so Puzza un pochino
No non sei tu come non sono io Questo è
profumo di umano Sono io sono io no
sentite sentite un po' Ah no PCI di
aglio puzz no ma questo non sei tu Vi ho
detto che non c'è nessuno che non c'è
niente a casa non c'è nessuno Dobbiamo
uscire a mangiare fa mangiamo fermo
ferma qua du ben tre umani sento tre
odori distinti Oh no sono
due non è che ci stai nascondendo
qualcuno io no no io non sto proprio
nascondendo nessuno però vi inviterei ad
uscire di casa si levi nonnina Ah
spostati è arrivato il momento di
poppari chiunque ci sia qui ehii cerca
di lì
B Sento puzza di cane bagnato e di umano
mm che strana questa pila di cuscini
sembra proprio fatta apposta Ah ho
capito chi c'è qui Ahia ecco di qua ho
trovato il lupo
impostore è fuori una quindi ma l
penseremo dopo e sei tu traditrice
Ah e adesso che abbiamo scoperto chi è
stata a tradirci proprio tu Io non me
l'aspettavo proprio da te ma se hai
detto che sono uscita dal Branco Sì ma
non non pensavo che ti schieri con gli
umani i nostri nemici Non sono nemici
gli umani sono simpatici A differenza
vostra Smettila di parlare a te
penseremo dopo Ora andiamo a cercarci
gli umani Infatti E tu stanne fuori
Esatto Vai a
cercare Fermi aspettate non ci sono
umani qua non non cercate è inutile non
ci sono non c'è nessuno Ah non ti
crediamo Sta zitta non ti
crediamo sento un certo odorino di umano
qui Ciao ciao
trovata e adesso Vieni
qui È arrivata l'ora della cena e
abbiamo appena trovato la
seconda non c'è nessun altro qua in
questa stanza e invece ti sbagli non c'è
mai due senza tre no no no no non c'è
nessuno non c'è nessuno ve lo giuro ci
manca Secondo me una persona ma dove si
può essere cacciata lì abbiamo trovato
la prima lì la
seconda lì la terza no no no no no non
c'è nessuno Ciao mia cara
bambina abbiamo trovato la nostra cena
ora vi mangiamo tutte quante Da quale
iniziamo Iniziamo
da tutte e
tre non penso proprio perché io le
difenderò tra
presto gli umani Ti trasformeranno in
pelliccia Ti sbagli cara volpe perché ho
scoperto che ci sono anche degli umani
buoni umani buoni ma buoni da mangiare
Ma no Sciocchino sta dicendo degli umani
buoni d'animo buoni bravi ma quindi
Esistono degli umani che non vogliono
fare di noi lupi delle pellicce Infatti
voi umani e lupi potreste raggiungere un
accordo e vivere serenamente in pace
insieme Sì dai troviamo un compromesso
io posso cucinare per tutti voi però
potete promettere di non mangiarci noi
non vi mangeremo se voi promettete di
non fare di noi delle
pellicce giurin giurello giurin
giurello Sì Guardate questo è per
te questo è per te Finalmente si mangia
[Applauso]
Sì mi sono perso
qualcosa Vitale Eccoti finalmente ce
l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo risolto anche
questo
[Applauso]
cartone rimane una cosa da fare 1 2
dovè andato a finire il lupo grande e
grosso no D qu la telecamera Oh mi
vergogno io non stavo ballando io non
ballo io non ballo Io mangio gli umani
non ballo non
ballo e invece ti abbiamo
visto
Ciao
i